waschbären in der brauerei füchse im
rotlichtviertel und entenküken auf den
balkon gästen immer mehr wildtiere
erobern deutschlands städte das bringt
probleme mit sich aber nicht nur denn es
gibt möglichkeiten wie auch die menschen
in der stadt von der u-bahn flora und
fauna profitieren können beispielsweise
mit spektakulärer white light fotografie
und dafür gibt es am ende des videos
noch ein goodie klicks umsatz im pfizer
gibt es dreimal pro woche spannende
science videos aber nicht den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen
dieses video ist in kooperation mit der
ct digitale fotografie entstanden dem
fachmagazin rund um digitale bilder und
am ende erwartet euch eine kleine
überraschung für foto-fans und durch die
unterstützung von ct digitale fotografie
ist dieses video auch komplett werbefrei
kein spaß die stadt kassel ist bekannt
als europas hauptstadt der waschbären
diese wildtiere haben mittlerweile die
gesamte stadt erobert die geschichte von
casanova gegen sogar durch die medien
ein waschbär der sich in kassel
gemütlich gemacht hatte seinen
schlafplatz hatte er sich in einer
brauerei eingerichtet und nachts machte
er touren durch das rotlichtmilieu der
stadt ganz schön clever denn in der
stadt gibt es nicht nur sichere
verstecke sondern vor allem auch
ausreichend nahrung viele der stadt
bären wohnen auf den dachböden der
häuser und machen sich nachts über die
mülltonnen her
es sind also wilde hausbesetzer manche
der waschbären sind echte städter andere
pendel noch zwischen den angrenzenden
waldgebieten und der stadt hin und her
doch es sind mittlerweile nicht nur
waschbären die in vielen größeren orten
zum stadtbild gehören in berlin
beispielsweise sind es außerdem auch
füchse und steinmarder die ursprünglich
eigentlich in felslandschaften und
steinbrüchen lebten der steinmarder hat
übrigens schon im mittelalter die stadt
als neuen lebensraum entdeckt dass immer
mehr wildtiere die städte erobern ist
kein wunder denn die städte nicht so in
deutschland wachsen jahr für jahr immer
weiter und somit auch in die
angrenzenden waldgebiete hinein die
landflucht der tiere liegt außerdem auch
daran dass sie durch die intensive forst
und landwirtschaftliche nutzung aus
ihrer ursprünglichen heimat verdrängt
werden doch klar ist auch die städte
bieten den wildtieren viele vorteile
natürliche feinde gibt es hier kaum in
den vorgärten und mülltonnen finden sie
eine reichliche auswahl an nahrung und
auch das klima in den innenstädten ist
milder und trockener als das klima in
der wildnis dazu volker homes vom wwf
artenschutzexpertin so viele
unterschiedliche biotope auf so engem
raum vor wie in der stadt wenn sie es
einmal geschafft haben sich hier einen
lebensraum zu erobern ist ihre
überlebenschance buch das einzige
problem für wildtiere in der stadt ist
der straßenverkehr doch auch damit
arrangieren sich die tiere mit der zeit
zu leben in vielen städten kaninchen auf
den verkehrsinseln von dicht befahrenen
straßen und werden dort viele jahre alt
auch die füchse haben sich gut an das
leben in der großstadt angepasst hat so
schreibt der bei linda naturschutzbund
nabu auf seiner webseite die tiere haben
sich perfekt an den trubel in der stadt
angepasst und eine geringe bis gar keine
fluchtdistanz gegenüber menschen und
ihren haustieren mehr
hier sind sie nicht nur nachts unterwegs
sondern auch am tage niemand stellt
ihnen hier nach die jagd ist im
befriedeten bereich nicht gestattet auch
der starke straßenverkehr hält die
anpassungsfähigen tiere nicht ab das
stadtgebiet weitgehend flächendeckend zu
besiedeln
am anfang der korona pandemie ging
kuriose bilder um die welt denn die
menschen deren städte wurden von
wildtieren eingenommen so zum beispiel
auf den luxus in barcelona hier flaniert
wildschweine genauso wie in anderen
spanischen städten im zentrum von madrid
stolzierten bunte bauen und in chiles
hauptstadt santiago war es ein junger
puma der für überraschung sorgte das
tier war wohl aus den bergen hinunter in
die wohngebiete kommen sicherheitshalber
wurde der puma betäubt und später dann
wieder ausgewildert in japan kamen die
sika hirsche in die großen städte und
schakale strohmatten mitten im zentrum
von tel aviv um herd die straßen in den
städten indiens und nepals wurden von
unzähligen hunden und affen heimgesucht
doch nichtsdestotrotz nicht alle städte
heißen die wildtiere im urbanen raum
willkommen hausbesitzerin und besitzer
in kassel beispielsweise fürchten sich
davor dass die waschbären riesige
schäden an ihren häusern anrichten der
jagdverband sieht die waschbär als eine
echte bedrohung für seltene arten wie
beispielsweise die sumpfschildkröte die
europäische union will die waschbären
eindämmen und hat die tiere des w
auf eine liste mit knapp 40 invasiven
gebietsfremden tier und pflanzenarten
gesetzt damit werden verstärkte
bemühungen gegen die ausbreitung dieser
arten gefordert und somit auch gegen die
waschbären natur und tierschützer
dagegen sehen die waschbären die
ursprünglich aus nordamerika kommen
schon längst als heimische art an sie
fordern die jagd einzustellen und
stattdessen das nahrungsangebot für die
tiere einzugrenzen konkret könnte obst
weggeräumt und müll und biotonnen
abgeschlossen werden
doch die wildtiere sind nicht mehr aus
den städten wegzudenken und so
beschäftigen sich zahlreiche forschende
damit so entstehen neue konzepte für die
artenvielfalt angestammte tierarten
können geschützt und neu angesiedelt
werden in der fachsprache ist vom animal
aided design die rede hierbei werden die
bedürfnisse der tiere von anfang an in
die städte planung mit einbezogen und
das hat nicht nur vorteile für die tiere
selbst für die dadurch beispielsweise
wertvolle nischen geschaffen werden
können auch die lebensqualität der
menschen die in der stadt leben die kann
dadurch verbessert werden dazu der
biologe wolfgang weisser aus leipzig wir
planen mit gebäuden wir planen mit
pflanzen aber wir planen nicht mit
tieren wir wissen eigentlich gar nicht
warum gewisse tiere dort vorkommen und
andere eben nicht bzw
wir wissen auch nicht wenn die tiere auf
einmal nicht mehr da sind warum sie
einfach nicht mehr da sind
verantwortlich für solche verluste sind
beispielsweise glasflächen an balkonen
die vögel nicht erkennen und dagegen
fliegen oder aber kellerschächte eine
falle für eidechsen die reinfallen und
nicht mehr heraus gelangen
dabei steckt dahinter ja nicht das ziel
diese tiere zu vernichten laut dem
animal and design ist es deswegen
wichtig sich solche beispiele für
ungewollte verluste bewusst zu machen
zudem werden nicht nur mitarbeiterinnen
und mitarbeiter aus der stadtplanung in
das konzept mit einbezogen sondern auch
hausbesitzerinnen und hausbesitzer
genauso wie mieterinnen und mieter die
idee zusammen kann man überlegen wie der
urbane raum bestmöglich für mensch und
tier genutzt werden kann
dazu der biologe wolfgang weisser in den
profession ist dieses wissen noch nicht
so vorhanden niemand der ein haus baut
geht als erstes zum örtlichen
vogelschutz verband und sagt wie muss
ich mein haus gestalten damit eine amsel
vorkommen kann
und es sind tatsächlich schon
kleinigkeiten die helfen den urbanen
lebensraum zu vernetzen kletterpflanzen
oder blühstreifen beispielsweise in den
vorgärten oder aber ein sandbad für
vögel unter einem baum schaffen oder
dieses direkt auf einem flachdach
anbieten wenn wir wild tiere in der
stadt zu lassen und pflanzen und tieren
den raum geben den sie brauchen dann
können auch wir menschen davon
profitieren dazu die biologin aletta
bonn
hier gibt es forschungen die zeigen dass
gerade in krisenzeiten natur auf
vielerlei arten therapeutisch wirken
kann
in der natur zu sein kann stress
reduzieren und auch dazu führen dass wir
uns glücklicher ausgeglichener und
weniger traurig fühlen
forschungsergebnisse zeigen dass eine
naturnahe umgebung mit größerer vielfalt
von vögeln zum beispiel eine
verminderung von stress bewölkt und es
gibt einen weiteren fordern vor allem
für die die gerne fotografieren stadt
nach afrika oder in die usa reisen zu
müssen um spektakuläre wildtier
fotografien zu machen ist das
mittlerweile auch in deutschen städten
möglich einer der angesagtesten waldlauf
fotografen der welt ist wird lukas der
vor allem mit außergewöhnlichen
weitwinkel und nachtaufnahmen
beeindruckt seine bilder sind wirklich
einzigartig denn der dritte benutzt
innovative kamera technologien wie die
selbst konstruierte beetle cam und
kamerafallen er konzentriert sich mit
seiner fotografie auf den afrikanischen
kontinent denn besonders zwei punkte
sind seiner meinung nach wichtig um an
gute geschichten zu kommen zum einen
sollte man sein terrain als fotograf in
oder fotograf gut kennen und zum anderen
benötigt man ein gutes
informationsnetzwerk sein tipp an alle
die walter fotos machen wollen es geht
darum neue sichtweisen und eine frische
ästhetik zu finden
voraussetzung dafür ist neben
experimentierfreude dass man sich auf
eine sache konzentriert eine tierart
beispielsweise oder eine bestimmte gegen
die muss nicht in der ferne sondern kann
eben auch vor der eigenen haustür liegen
klar ist aber nur wenn man sich über
monate oder jahre mit einem budget
beschäftigt lernt man wie man zur
buchstäblich ungesehenen bildern kommt
doch will dort lukas ist nicht nur
begnadeter fotograf sondern eben auch
erfinder immer auf der suche nach neuen
bildern und es tätigen und so bastelte
er eine art kamera buggy den er selbst
als bitte gern bezeichnet dieses gefährt
besteht aus einem miniatur fahrzeug das
man verstehen kann und auf dem in einem
kunst
gehäuse eine kamera sicher befestigt
werden kann nicht nur das gefährt selbst
sondern auch die kamera lässt sich mit
hilfe einer fernbedienung fernsteuern
dieses teil namens beetle camp macht
seinem namen wirklich alle ehre es
kriecht wie ein käfer über den boden und
so gelangen dem walter fotografen
spektakuläre aufnahmen von überaus
wilden tieren mit dabei elefanten
leoparden löwen und außerdem auch
büffelt er selbst befindet sich dabei in
sicherer entfernung in seinem jeep doch
seine beetle cam ermöglicht ihm wirklich
hautnah shots mit diesem selbst
kreierten gefährt gelang es robert lukas
sogar die seltenen tosca elefanten im
zoo wo ist nationalpark in kenia zu
fotografieren eine sensation denn von
diesen tieren gibt es weltweit nur noch
etwa 20 stück die zweite leidenschaft
des britischen fotografen sind
nachtaufnahmen bilder tiere vor allem
der sagenumwobene schwarze leopard oder
auch schwarzer panther hat es wilbert
lukas angetan
doch wie sollte er dieses nachtaktive
und äußerst schreibt hier vor die linse
bekommen
dazu sagt er für mich gibt es kein
schönes tier doch ich kannte niemanden
der ein black panther jemals in freier
wildbahn gesehen hatte ich hatte nicht
einmal ein qualitativ hochwertiges bild
eines wilden schwarzen leoparden aus
afrika gesehen
zufällig erzählt mir freunde das im
laikipia war das camp in kenia eine
aufgetaucht war
hier stellte robert lukas mehrere
kammern fallen auf mit erfolg
und so wurde er auch hier zum erfinder
und entwickelte für seine zwecke ein
eigenes system ein kammer gehäuse samt
tubus sowie einem oder mehreren
bewegungssensoren der wald da fotograf
will eben nicht auf erfindungen anderer
warten entwickelt die technischen
lösungen zu seinen bildern selbst ein
totales alleinstellungsmerkmal aber auch
andere walter fotografinnen und
fotografen können davon profitieren sei
es nun in der echten wildnis afrikas
oder aber wenn es um fotos von wilden
tieren in deutschlands städten geht wie
genau das geht erfahrt ihr in der ct
digitale fotografie und als klicks um zu
schauen dann bekommt ihr jetzt sogar
eine digitale ausgabe gratis mit vielen
profitipps fundierten workshops und
spannenden how to anleitung außerdem
findet ihr dank der umfangreichen
produkttests von kameras objektive und
fotozubehör auf jeden fall das richtige
equipment probiert es aus es kostet
nichts alles was ihr dafür tun müsst ist
hier auf den link zu klicken oder die
aktion über die video
aufzurufen bis dann bleibt dran